Hey there power-crazed viewers, Trace here.
Internet hero Nikola Tesla dreamed of delivering
power wirelessly to the masses.
Of course, that was over a century ago, and
here we are today with “wireless phones”
that are anything but.
Researchers at Disney, yes, the cartoon/amusement
park juggernauts, have decided that simply
will not do, and they are trying to solve
the problem with a little Disney magic.
And science.
Mostly science.
Wireless charging pads have existed for a
while now, but they’re far from perfect.
They work by running a high frequency alternating
current through a circular coil, which creates
a magnetic field.
That field induces a current in another circular
coil in the receiving device, and the device
converts it to direct current.
Presto change-o, your battery is charging
wirelessly.
We actually have a whole video about it.
I'm sure you get that the device isn’t physically
tethered to those charging spots, but just
because of that, if it’s picked up or moved
off the pad just a bit, and the juice stops
flowing.
Therefore, unless you just can’t stand the
sight of cables, wireless charging is still
not perfect.
The real holy grail would be wireless charging
at a distance.
Something that can keep you topped up while
you walk around and using your phone.
Researchers at Disney think they have an answer
to this.
Their solution was to design an entire room
that basically functioned as a giant three-dimensional
charging pad.
You’d never even know it was different from
any other room, aside that conspicuous copper
pole right in the middle of it.
If you look closely at the copper pole and
you’ll see a gap towards the top.
In that gap are small discrete capacitors.
By combining those capacitors with a signal
generator and they can send alternating current
through the pole, the walls, the ceiling and
the floor at the frequency of their choice.
This creates a magnetic field around the pole,
and just like with current wireless chargers
on the market, if you have a receiver that
resonates at the right frequency, you’ve
got wireless charging almost anywhere in the
room.
Still, t’s not perfect.
Unless your phone and the receiver coil inside
are perpendicular to the magnetic field, nothing
is getting charged.
And of course, there’s the issue of safety.
The room can transmit enough power to charge
over 300 smartphones without exceeding the
government’s safety guidelines for how much
power a body can absorb, so long as you’re
standing more than 46 centimeters away the
pole, you shouldn't have to worry.
Also, it's probably best not to touch it.
Anything practical would need a shut-off mechanism
if a person got too close, or a wall around
the pole to keep people far enough away.
The researchers note though it’s important
that something actually consumes that power
since whatever goes unused is stored in the
room, and could be potentially harmful.
So future systems would need something to
monitor how much power is being used too.
There's a long way to go here.
The researchers are optimistic this technology
could be scaled for a variety of uses, from
small charging cabinets to warehouses that
use multiple poles.
Since this was developed by Disney, don’t
be surprised if future theme parks advertise
that your phone will magically never go dead,
while all the rooms suddenly have mysterious
pillars in the middle.
We can't do episodes like this without some
help from our sponsors.
When you buy a domain name from domain.com,
you're taking the first steps in creating
an identity and vision for your brand.
No domain extension will help tell your story
like a .com or .net domain name.
Get 15% off domain.com's already affordable
web hosting and domain names when you use
the coupon code "Seeker" at checkout.
So this technique of wireless charging still
isn’t perfect, but maybe your phone’s
own radio waves could make your battery last
longer.
Amy’s got the science on that here.
So would you put up with an awkward pole in
the middle of your living room if it meant
you never had to plug your phone in again?
Let us know in the comments, make sure you
subscribe for more videos and thanks for tuning
in.